افاده مراسل الجزيره شرقيه اوكرانيا بان
المعارك مستمره على طول الخطوط لمواجهه في
اقليم دومباس وقالت مصادر عسكريه اوكرانيه
للجزيره من المعارك الاشرس تدور حاليا في
مدينه باخبط حيث تحاول القوات الروسيه
السيطره على مصانع عده شرقيه المدينه كما
اكدت المصادر ان حده الهجوم الروسي خفت في
اجلدار بعد تكبد القوات الروسيه خسائر
وصفتها بالكبيره من جانب الاخر قال عضو
المجلس الرئاسي من الاداره العسكريه
والمدنيه لروسيا في زاباروسيا ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تتسحبت من خط الدفاع الاول في
المدينه
في روايه المقابله اكدت مواقع تابعه
الروسيه انها تمكنت من السيطره على مواقع
على القوات الاوكرانيه في الاحياء الشرقيه
والجنوبيه من مدينه باخموت والنفاكنر عقب
سيطرتها على مدينه
تستمر بالتقدم وتوسيع مساحه الاراضي
الخاضعه لسيطرتها في محوري